why do you think it is that there's more
gay men than gay women that continues to
be debated you have to understand the
scientific issue is how does almost
reality continue at all why is it not
competed out of the gene pool nature is
against it since it doesn't reproduce
there are genes that predict
homosexuality and it's not a particular
gay gene as they were once saying and
the interesting finding is that the
siblings of the gays as more social
Partners than the average man the super
manly man who only is entirely masculine
in all his traits he doesn't relate to
women all that well so it becomes a
hit-the-middle problem you want to have
more of these genes which will produce
more feminine traits in the man but
maybe Beyond a certain amount maybe a
high amount then turns him to where he'd
be more attracted to other men but the
same configuration of genes just a
little bit on the other side of the
Border produces extra children by making
the others more attractive and that's
enough to keep the genes replenished in
each generation so it will continue to
appear